[Music]
on this sunday night heading into the
home stretch of the election campaign
federal leaders fan out across the
country we'll explain their latest
promises and how two former liberal mps
are causing problems for the party
passports please bc prepares to become
the latest province to require proof of
vaccination for non-essential services
as charlottetown shutters schools
education segregation the taliban
reveals its plans for women in the
classroom
plus miami football fans make a perfect
catch
[Applause]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we are now heading into the final
week of the election campaign leaders of
the three main federal parties fanned
out across the country today from quebec
to bc making one final push to shore up
support ahead of september the 20th
recent opinion polls are predicting an
extremely close race certainly not the
outcome justin trudeau was counting on
when he called the early election and
today a former member of trudeau's team
announced that for the first time in her
life she's voting conservative abigail
beeman is traveling with the liberal
campaign and brings us the details
abigail
jeff selena cesar chavan left the
liberal caucus in 2019 the month after
jody wilson ravel resigned her cabinet
position in an interview on the west
block she talks about reading the
excerpt from wilson ravel's new book and
crying i wasn't heartbroken because some
of the feeling that was in that room was
so familiar to me i was heartbroken
because we keep continuing to reward
bad behavior from a prime minister
that um that won a 2019 election had a
majority and and a minority government
so for six years continues to say there
is more to do
cesar chavanne says she's a liberal at
heart but this election she will do
something she's never done in her life
vote for her local conservative
candidate a decision she says based on
trudeau's leadership and behavior she
also talked about her disappointment
with trudeau's handling of this exchange
with green party leader anime paul
during the english debate i have said
before and i'll say again tonight that i
do not believe that mr trudeau is a real
feminist a feminist doesn't continue to
push strong women out of his um out of
his party uh when they are just seeking
to serve
you'll perhaps understand that i won't
take lessons on caucus management from
you i asked trudeau what selena cesar
chavann's decision means to him as he
continues to call himself a feminist
i
wish celine all the best
people have a really important choice to
make in this election
do we move forward on
ten dollar a day child care right across
the country
and on the question of the snc lavalin
affair thrust back into the spotlight
with the release of wilson ravel's new
book sunday trudeau said he has never
been contacted by the rcmp about the
issue
jeff
abigail beeman traveling with the
liberal campaign tonight thanks abigail
conservative leader erin o'toole was in
vancouver today announcing commitments
to improve bereavement benefits for
parents who lose a child as our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports it's part of a broader effort to
appeal to female voters
over a summer my family
said goodbye to our youngest daughter
lucy rose after only 39 days
it was the sad experience of
conservative mp tom kmich and liberal mp
sean fraser who also lost an infant
daughter in 2019 that prompted a
parliamentary committee to recommend
changes to parental bereavement leave
benefits recommendations aaron o'toole
promises to implement
well the fraser family i sent them a
note because my wife and i were
heartbroken by that situation and of
course tom is our caucus chair and i've
spoken
a lot
on the strain
every year in canada as many as 1600
babies die before their first birthday
so if elected a conservative government
would modify the employment insurance
system to extend parental leave benefits
by eight weeks in the event of the death
of a child create a new bereavement
leave of up to eight weeks if a child
dies
and provide three days of paid leave for
those who experience a miscarriage the
last thing you should have to worry
about is your job or your benefits when
you're taking time to grieve
and to heal
it was unclear how o'toole's promise
would mesh with existing provincial and
federal bereavement plans but the
initiative is part of a package of
policy proposals the conservatives are
making to win female voters and i want
more women
to look in a mirror on september 20th
and say you know what i'm going to vote
conservative when stephen harper won his
majority in 2011 the party did well with
women but ever since then the party has
struggled to connect with women the way
that liberals and new democrats have so
doing better on that demographic score
will be critical to conservative success
next week at the polls jeff
david aiken reporting from the
conservative party campaign thanks david
the ndp campaign meanwhile is sticking
to its tax the rich strategy in the
battle for ontario jagmeet singh was in
sudbury today where he's hoping the ndp
can win a liberal-held riding singh
repeated his plans to close corporate
loopholes that allow big business to pay
less tax
we are losing 25 billion dollars a year
in unrecovered revenue 25 billion a year
over six years is nearly 150 billion
dollars of revenue that we're losing
yesterday the ndp laid out the cost of
the party's platform including a wealth
tax that would raise nearly 11 billion
dollars and corporations that profit
beyond their projections would also be
taxed generating 14 and a half billion
dollars that money would then be used to
fund health care climate change policy
and indigenous reconciliation to the
pandemic now and starting tomorrow
people in british columbia will need to
provide proof of covit 19 vaccination to
access various venues and services
british columbians must produce a
digital or paper copy of a qr code in
order to enter restaurants nightclubs
movie theaters and gyms proof of
vaccination will also be required for
indoor concerts and ticketed sporting
events as well as other indoor
gatherings such as weddings with more
than 50 people anyone over the age of 19
will also need to show photo id manitoba
and quebec have already implemented
similar measures ontario will follow
suit on september the 22nd
well the new school year is just
underway but climbing covet 19 cases in
charlottetown have now led to the
suspension of in-person learning at
several schools their students will now
move to remote online learning for at
least the next few days 10 of the last
11 cases in pei are among children under
the age of 19. it marks the province's
first outbreak of covet 19 in a school
and the school year in many parts of the
united states began in early august and
the number of children hospitalized with
covid19 in the u.s reached a record high
last week with many states grappling
with surging case numbers in an effort
to bring the pandemic under control
president joe biden recently imposed new
vaccine requirements that will affect
millions of americans as jennifer
johnson reports the policy is facing
pushback and possible lawsuits
covet 19 is still killing more than 1
500 americans a day the centers for
disease control says the risk of dying
is 11 times higher for the unvaccinated
doctors call these unnecessary deaths
how quickly we get to a level where
cases are low and stay low really
depends on what we do collectively not
just the government but each of us as
private citizens we need to do more
president joe biden declared war
thursday on over 30 percent of
unvaccinated americans ordering millions
of federal employees and contractors and
health care workers to get vaccinated
and demanding large private employers
mandate shots or require weekly testing
the president really just made it very
simple
this is a pandemic that we can end the
people who are blocking it can no longer
be allowed to block it period already
some republicans are pushing back saying
the president has overstepped his powers
which will lead to more vaccine
resistance this is an unprecedented
assumption of federal
mandate authority that really disrupts
and divides the country this is
something that every state has to make
decisions on many parts of the country
are still locked in battles over mask
and vaccine mandates the item passes los
angeles schools are now requiring coven
19 vaccines for students 12 and over but
some experts say expected legal
challenges will likely fail since there
are already laws mandating other
vaccines for school children they stand
on very firm legal grounds it will be
really difficult to challenge them
even though for a certain age group some
of these vaccines are only under
emergency use approval the american
academy of pediatrics says children now
represent a quarter of all weekly covet
19 cases vaccine makers are rushing to
get emergency approval for vaccines for
five to 11 year olds some doctors
believe those could be available by
halloween
jennifer johnson global news washington
to the situation in afghanistan now and
fears for the future of education for
women since seizing control of the
country last month the taliban has
attempted to present itself as
respecting women's rights the militant
group now says it will allow women to
attend university albeit in separate
classrooms from their male counterparts
and in kabul the taliban even paraded a
group of women who purportedly support
its tactics but as mike drollet explains
many others are now living in fear
this is the demonstration the taliban
wants the world to see female students
fully veiled carrying propaganda signs
in english celebrating the taliban's
decision to allow women to attend
university afghanistan's minister for
higher education made the announcement
with some caveats the teachers have to
be women and not all courses will be
taught
the taliban tasered and beat this group
of students to expect education as they
know it to end
you know you might have women attend
university but basically being
taught what uh the taliban's
interpretation of the quran and islamic
law is
for
female roles in society and female
behavior for instance so you know if
it's so i suspect it'll just be an
indoctrination exercise
much of this was expected the taliban
are trying to appear legitimate so girls
have been allowed in school provided
they're separated from boys
but it's also precarious members of
afghanistan's all-female orchestra have
gone into hiding because the taliban
hate music it remains unclear whether it
will be forbidden as it was 25 years ago
and the question remains if ultimately
the taliban will try to form a
legitimate government or rule through
violence i think certainly when you put
a key operative in the haqqani network
as your interior minister it sends a
very clear message that violence uh
terrorism you know somebody who has a 10
million dollar bounty on their head
by the united states
that
there are carrots here and there are
sticks
and they've clearly put somebody with
who wheels a very big and hard stick in
charge as the interior minister after 40
years the wars may be over but the
internal conflict remains microlight
global news
toronto still ahead 20 years since 9 11
victims say their cries for help remain
unanswered
commemorations were held around the
world this weekend to mark a somber
milestone two decades since 9 11 and in
recent years terrorism has hit even
closer to home in canada since 2017 22
people have been killed in more than a
dozen attacks with links to extremism
but despite that growing number of
victims critics say the government's
response is uncoordinated and inadequate
so i really want to share this with you
maureen beznicki carries memories of her
husband ken including this photograph
this is the missing persons
distributed to people in new york city
in the days after september 11 2001. 20
years later
most days it seems like yesterday
for me
ken was on the 106th floor of the world
trade center when two planes crashed
into the twin towers one of 24 canadians
killed this calling card his only
belonging recovered from the rubble
and so when the nypd said they had his
calling card
it's just such a wonderful feeling for
me it's
it's canada's own way saying honey i'm
home
maureen was a flight attendant the newly
widowed mother of two suffered
post-traumatic stress disorder and
couldn't return to work
but instead of support the federal
government sent her an income tax bill
for her deceased husband she racked up
180 thousand dollars in legal bills
fighting governments and insurance
companies it was horrible i was unable
to complete forms i got frustrated i got
angry
i just wanted to cocoon and try to heal
she spent the past 20 years giving
speeches and testimony calling for
better supports for victims of terrorism
her victories include legislation that
allows victims to sue state sponsors of
terrorism like iran but she says canada
has a long way to go
in london ontario muslims gather at the
local mosque for friday prayers watched
by privately hired police guards and
cameras beefed up security measures
still in place following june's
terrorist attack when a pickup truck ran
over a muslim family killing four
members the majority from what i've seen
are still kind of looking over their
shoulder uncertain
in the aftermath political leaders of
all stripes came to pay their respects
we appreciate their presence at the
vigil but at the same time it can't just
be another thing that we spoke about
once and now it's in the rearview mirror
the imam says they've received no
financial help from any level of
government to deal with the aftermath
his mosque is now spending nearly ten
thousand dollars a month on security and
overwhelmed by the demand for mental
health supports these people are already
at capacity so we need funding to expand
their services so people have a place
where they can just go and talk to a
therapist talk to a counselor
20 years since maureen first cried out
for better supports for victims of
terrorism those calls remain unanswered
still ahead 911 and gen zed how that
tragic day has touched the lives of some
who weren't even born yet
you're watching global national
[Music]
welcome back most of us remember where
we were and what we were doing 20 years
ago when the news broke of a terrorist
attack in new york city except of course
for the younger generation but even
those born after 9 11 or too young to
remember say that day left an indelible
mark and gaviola explains and a warning
this story contains disturbing imagery
september 11 2001 was a turning point in
historian michael petrue's life as a
journalist he was in afghanistan
covering the fallout of the attacks
embedded with northern alliance troops
you're in trenches and the
taliban were a few hundred meters away
and the northern alliance the taliban
would shoot back and forth and
trash talk each other on the radios but
those events resonate differently with
people under the age of 25. many weren't
alive when 9 11 happened i probably
heard about it in the
context of like restrictions and the
ways that like life has changed
after and the ways that we move and we
travel now they may have learned about 9
11 second hand but they've also learned
about terrorism first hand i feel like
it was the first terrorist attack i've
seen that i've continued to see more
even growing up
especially with the manchester bombings
that happened at the ariana grande
concert the paris attacks some suffered
personal attacks based on ignorance
hearing comments like oh are you related
to osama bin laden like oh like muslims
are terrorists and all of those because
that's what had shaped a lot of people's
perception of islam um so hearing like
the racist comments and like the
islamophobia and all of that that
definitely stuck with me for a long time
the consequences of actions taken by
political leaders as a result of 9 11
continue to resonate today with everyone
else young people have watched the
recent withdrawal of western troops from
afghanistan the two feelings that i have
the most are just
anger and anguish the whole reason that
people justified the war was that it was
going to stop terrorism it was going to
stop impunity it was going to stop the
way that organizations like the taliban
just take out their
um ideology against women and ethnic and
religious minorities they're trying to
make sense of those events and criticize
the actions of people during those
events without that sort of
background music of shock and horror and
anger and trauma and revenge seeking
each generation processing the events of
9 11 in their own way ann gaviola global
news toronto
stairs that care up next how these
robotic gazes can help protect our most
vulnerable
oh take a look at this fur raising video
florida football fans were on the edge
of their seats last night not from the
game but because of a cat spotted
clinging to the stadium's upper deck to
everyone's dismay the cat lost its grip
now fortunately fans below broke the
feline's fall using an american flag it
bounced off unscathed and was whisked
away by security with all of its nine
lives still intact
as our population ages caregivers are
looking for new and innovative ways to
provide much needed support even
something as simple as a loving gaze can
have a significant emotional impact well
now some researchers in europe have come
up with a novel solution as redmond
shannon reports they're sending robots
to the rescue
disturbing isn't it
the uncanny valley it's called it's the
phenomenon where we find something that
looks almost but not quite human
unsettling this is like
you see how awkward my first dates are
it's a robot
it isn't an issue with robots like icub
at the italian institute of technology
however researchers there wanted to know
if its cartoon-like features could still
be arresting gaze is an extremely
important social signal that we employ
on a day-to-day basis scientists asked
volunteers to play a video game of
chicken against the robot you know the
one decide to drive straight or swerve
at the last minute
sometimes the robot gazed at the human
beforehand sometimes it didn't what we
have found is in that in fact
the gaze of the robot the mutual gaze of
the robot
affected decisions by delaying them so
humans were
much slower in making the decisions and
in the game
in other words
psych so our results show that um
actually the human brain processes the
robot gaze as a social signal and that
signal has an impact on the way we're
making decisions it could be an
important finding because of many
countries aging demographics and the
impending shortage of care workers think
of for example
a robot that assists an elderly person
in
reminding the person to take their
medication
if a robot displays social behaviors it
might be that the elderly person will be
more likely to follow the advice of the
robot for now a robot will always be a
poor substitute for a human caregiver
but for many smaller tasks that vital
sense of connection
could make a difference
just ask the eerie sofia i can help
communicate give therapy and provide
social stimulation researchers say it
will also be important to learn the
downsides of a robotic gaze so that
robots don't distract humans when we
really need to concentrate redmond
shannon global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
your canada is the sunset over the
fraser river in new westminster british
columbia thanks for watching pharah
nasser will be at the anchor desk with
you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you